more than 6
000 kilometers and seven time zones away
from the capital
the people of kobarovsk are demanding
the kremlin
set things right by setting their
governor free what's happening to
governor fergal
is an injustice and in violation of all
conceivable human rights
i can't be indifferent to this
we're marching for democracy but it is
very fleeting for us
we walk in fear that tomorrow will be
locked up for anything
the region's governor sergey fergul has
been on a moscow jail since early july
accused of being involved in the murders
of business rivals before he got into
politics
fergal denies the charges his supporters
say the arrest is delayed retaliation
for his 2018 gubernatorial victory
frugal's opposition
win was a humiliating setback for the
maine kremlin party
president putin's united russia
they're robbing us of our choice that
election was a window that gave us a
glimpse of democracy
but the kremlin has closed it we are
protesting to open it again
not just for us but all of russia
because all of russia is in the same
situation
thousands of protesters have been
demanding foregone's freedom
for four straight weeks their message is
spreading across the far east region
and the country at least 10 other cities
have joined in solidarity
including st petersburg
i believe we're one country and we
should stick together and support
kobarovsk
because lots of people there are
fighting for their freedom of choice
and we support them in this
putin has appointed another opposition
lawmaker to replace frugal
but the governor has earned the respect
of the people back home
by cutting his salary and offering new
benefits
they call him the people's governor and
they say they won't stop
fighting for fergal until he's free
you